listening in on a
weather update from spacex and nasa for
a go no go for departure today
the latest window for departure will be
9
25 a.m but we are currently targeting
9 a.m central time 10 a.m eastern time
for an undocking and separation of the
vehicle from the space station
we will continue to watch the weather
and the splash
down sights off the coast of the
atlantic in
florida
you currently are seeing live views of
the drag cargo dragon vehicle attached
to the harmony module
on the space facing side of the port
again this is the second cargo vehicle
the second dragon vehicle that is
attached to the space station
this is a first for spacex
crew dragon launched in november
with the crew won astronauts award
the cargo dragon spacecraft brought up
around 5
200 pounds of research and return
cargo splashing we are looking for the
spacecraft
to return five thousand two hundred
pounds of cargo and research
and it will be a first as well as this
has
we will receive science investigations
at the kennedy space center and it'll be
the first
since the shuttle program
the station and dragon are currently
flying over
the south pacific ocean
about 264 statute miles above
there are currently seven crew members
aboard the station
from the left is nasa astronaut kate
rubens
victor glover shannon walker
jack says nasa astronaut i'm sorry
jackson astronaut suicina gucci
along with i'm sorry
victor glover shannon walker jackson
astronaut soichino gucci
all makeup expedition 64.
again we are standing by for dragon's
departure or undocking currently
scheduled for
9 a.m central time 10 a.m eastern time
this all will be dependent on weather
and we are still evaluating
the last time to call for departure
today will be 9
25 a.m
we have gotten happy with weather off
florida
and with that in preparation for undock
i'd like you to perform step
one of one decimal 602 dragon departure
monitoring
1.602 step one inward
undock sequence start time one four five
five
start time one four five five copy good
copy
he's sensational just stand down on a
red until we've got we're past the no
exercise time
copy houston
dragon undocking departure review
complete iss crew is ready for departure
copy iss crew ready for departure
and that was confirmation from the
capcom to the crew
that we are currently go for departure
today
and we're looking for commands to be
sent
for departure and undocking to be 8 55
am
and physical separation from the vehicle
from the iss will be 9 a.m
central time 10 a.m eastern time
we're currently in a brief handover
between satellites right now but we'll
be retaining communications here shortly
you are currently seeing a live view of
the international space station flight
control room
if you're just joining us we are
standing by
for a undocking of the or departure
of the spacex dragon cargo vehicle
having arrived on december 7 2020 with
over 6
500 pounds of cargo today you're
watching the first
autonomous undocking of a cargo dragon 2
vehicle
upon dragon's departure today currently
scheduled for around 9 a.m
central time it will depart with just
over 4
500 pounds of critical science and other
hardware scheduled for a safe splash
down
off the coast of florida in the atlantic
and we're looking for splashdown around
808 pm central time
908 pm eastern time
the command to release dragon will
originate from the flight controllers
here on the ground
and in hawthorne that command will be
sent
from
i'm sorry that command will be sent from
either
it could be sent from either astronauts
aboard the station or ground team
and while the command won't come from
the own orbit crew today
nasa astronaut victor glover will be
standing by in the cupola module and
monitoring the spacecraft's departure
there are a couple milestones we'll see
dragon meat this morning
first those departure burns
but then it will cross the keep out
sphere
an invisible line around the station
with about
with a 200 meter radius it will keep
heading away from the station and will
stand by
until it makes its way out of the
approach ellipsoid
another invisible line that's one
kilometer by one kilometer by two
kilometers around the station
these invisible lines are where we have
checkpoints for the vehicle on its way
to
and from the station
once the command is set there will be
two sets of hooks from the international
space station and dragon that will be
released
and springs from the crew dragon will
push
the vehicle away from the international
space station
the question if you wanted to delay the
start of your upcoming pmc
after separation the spacecraft will
start to slowly drift away from the
space station dragon has a few
small departure burns to get it into the
proper position away from the station
for its eventual deorbit burn
currently scheduled for 7 18 pm central
time
that will slow dragon down enough to
drop it out of orbit and send it towards
its
landing zone splashing down in the
atlantic
approximately around 9 00 p.m
central time t 10 p.m eastern time
station houston on two with dragon
undock pending we are entering no
exercise period
station houston on two for dragon
departure we are
no go for today due to weather
as you just heard we are waving off
today due to poor weather off the coast
of daytona
spacex and nasa will be evaluating what
would be a better time
to have undocking for the spacecraft
please watch nasa.gov
for updated timelines
for when cargo dragon will be departing
that'll wrap up our coverage for the
undocking of dragon today
and please watch nasa.gov for updated
timelines of
when dragon will be go for undocking
this is mission control houston
so
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well in my left hand i have a feather
and my right hand a hammer i guess one
of the reasons
uh we got here today was because of a
gentleman named galileo a long time ago
who made a rather significant discovery
about falling objects in gravity fields
and we thought that uh where would be a
better place
to confirm his uh findings and on the
moon
and so we thought we'd try it here for
you the feather happens to be
appropriately a falcon feather
station houston are you ready for the
event
listen we are ready for the event
houston acr this is houston mission
control please call station for a voice
check
station this is houston acr how do you
hear me
i have you loud and clear welcome aboard
the space station
hello to astronauts aboard the
international space station
and after school students everywhere i'm
ridgeway white of the mott foundation
through million girls moonshot and the
mizzen by mod app
we're working to help you explore new
worlds
and today thanks to nasa you're about to
share an experience
that's out of this world now let's go to
our first question for astronauts
shannon walker and kate rubens
hi my name is durian scott and i attend
cardinal ritter college preparatory high
school
and i'm representative of girls inc
incorporated of st
louis my question for you today is as we
move into the new year
what are some new things we should
expect from nasa
oh my there is so much going on at nasa
you wouldn't even believe it
let's first start with the artemis
program that's our program when we're
going to take people back to the moon
we expect to have our first uncrewed
test launch this year
followed soon by people going to the
moon
then we've got the space station where
kate and i are now
there is a ton of science going on here
it's unbelievable
soon in a couple of months if you can
believe that we're going to have crew 2.
we're going to have another crew coming
up here
we actually have a new airlock on the
space station where we can take science
samples in and out that's going to be
great
that's just the human space light side
we've got all our unmanned stuff
going on in the solar system as well
we've got our mo
rovers on mars we've got satellites
around mars we've got satellites around
planets
and even did you know that we have
satellites that we launched when we were
young
that are outside the solar system and we
are still talking to them
there's so much going on at nasa it's
unbelievable
hi my name is nina deluna and i attend
thomas fleming school